what is going on everybody sorry for the
delay in videos posting we've been
really busy here on the property
and one of those things we've been doing
is growing grass or trying to grow grass
in this video what we're going to be
doing is hooking up that
two-inch trash pump from harbor freight
to a normal sprinkler system
i didn't know if you could do this so i
looked up on youtube and i started
looking around online and people
were doing it but they kind of left out
that little
important part like what is needed to do
it and can this pump do it without
any additional adjustments to the pump
so of course the big thing that comes to
mind is this thing pushes a massive
amount of water uh in relation to
what a normal hose does but the water
pressure doesn't seem to be
different now i didn't know if you could
block
the pump on the water pump and still
have it run like if there was a bypass
valve
or i still don't however i do know
that this does work without any
modification to the actual pump housing
itself
you will need a couple little pieces and
i'll show you what i did it's
frankenstein
so bear with me but if you have a better
way of doing this go ahead and post them
down in the comments
we're going from a two-inch hose down to
a normal garden hose which might be like
8 garden hose which is your normal
garden hose so i went down to the parts
store and i put together this
frankenstein
all right so what we have here is a
frankenstein if you look at this
this thing seems crazy but it actually
does a lot that i need it to so
first off it's good for when i'm putting
chemicals
or wanting to spray the pond i did it
earlier it's like a fire hose man i'll
tell you what this thing shot all the
way across the pond
but let me go over what this is so you
guys could uh possibly go and pick this
up and build something like this
yourself
this is a two inch standard adapter with
a screw
uh it is the only thread size that i've
seen so this just screwed right on to
the tip
no questions asked so don't worry about
the thread on that but this is a two
inch
uh female coupler
and then you got a two inch reducer down
to an inch and a half reducer
and then the next piece here is a
inch and a half reducer down to a three
quarter inch reducer
the three quarter inch reducer is a
threaded three quarter inch reducer
and then it has a threaded
three-quarter inch thread to
a three-quarter inch pipe
now this three-quarter inch pvc pipe is
two feet long i picked it up i did not
cut it and that's why i put it
together looking like this ginormous
thing on the very
end of this i have the same adapter
on the other from the other side a
three-quarter inch
to a three-quarter inch thread
this thread happens to screw right into
the end of the hose
so i can screw the hose onto this and
then run
the hose to the sprinkler system and the
sprinkler system
actually works guys it's kind of crazy
let's go ahead and
hook up the hose to this and show you
guys
how this connects how it looks and then
we're going to start this up and i'm
going to show you that it
literally just works
all right so we have our garden hose and
then we have this
crazy little contraption that i just
went over you with
this little this big adapter piece is
connected to the flat
hose two inch hose that you would pick
up from harbor freight for the two inch
trash pump
and it just screws right into the pvc
pipe
and like i said before the end adapter
will go into a basic
or standard hose
and it just screws right on
no problem now this is a little loose it
does spray a little bit
it leaks a little bit but it gets the
job done
so let's go ahead and let's turn on the
pump
and see what we got
[Music]
all right so there it is it seems to be
working i have the pump on low just for
reference
but the pump seems to be working it
seems to be spraying just fine
again the garden hose it leaks a little
bit here
but it's just water from the pond so i'm
not too worried about it
the pump is on low it's just idling so
we're going to go ahead and turn it up
and see what happens
all right so i turned it up about uh
about a quarter way of what the pump is
and this thing
is just pumping away i don't see any
issue at all
guys i think this is gonna work just
fine for anybody's use
the big question is if i take that off
of there
and then i hook up the normal like a
hand
the hand tool i can't think of it right
now post dominant confidence but
if i hook it up to the hand piece and
then i don't use it
what will happen to the pump does it
have a bypass is it going to break
but this is pretty cool uh this works
literally with doing nothing to the pump
and it pumps it
right down into a normal hose and then
right into a sprinkler system
again i seen this video posted on
youtube all over the place
but it didn't really address the simple
question that i had
will my pump do it without any
modification and the answer is
yes it seems like it is yet all right so
now the question is
will it work with this will it work on
and off and what will happen if i don't
use it and i just let it sit there
all right so here's the deal i have it
hooked up to the hose i'm going to start
the pump on low
have the handle fully open and
see what happens we know guys from the
sprinkler system obviously
this is going to work
but what will happen when we take it off
that is the big question
it works just like you had your
sprinkler system on
your water pressure on all right making
going to turn this off and see what
happens
nothing happens the pump doesn't even
change
it takes a minute for it to kick in pull
it and it gives a minute
let's go ahead and turn it up see what
happens
all right ready
let's go all the way
all right so you might be saying justin
you're an idiot
we i knew that like we all knew that i'm
gonna say
i didn't i did not know that that pump
would do that so
now i know and hopefully you know
that you can hook up your two inch trash
pump or just
i'm gonna assume that you can go across
the board with these type of pumps from
harbor freight or whoever sells them
that you can go from that pump to an
adapter to a normal hose
to a sprinkler system for irrigation in
this case it is irrigation on some form
i need to water some grass and get some
grass going
this means i can go over to my garden on
this side and do that
and i can also eventually we're going to
be putting a
garden over there an actual like tilled
garden with the tractor
and i could irrigate that too as well
this is a great little
like find that i i
seen online and i'm glad that i figured
it out and it put it went together so
easy guys it was
super easy so now i can
i'm actually more happy uh that i can
clean my four-wheeler
and tractor off here instead of doing it
at home
so my neighbors don't get mad at me in
my neighborhood when there's a
mud river running down down the road so
i hope this helped you out if you had
any doubts or
maybe you didn't even know that you
could do this go ahead and please
consider subscribing to the channel
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up if you have any questions or comments
about what i just did
about the pump or anything about the
channel go ahead and post them down in
the comments
i'd love to hear from you until next
time get outside and stay safe